We are going to use EDirect to access a local
installation of PubMed.
I am Peter Cooper, and as I said, Jonathan
Kans is sort of mind behind EDirect and he
is with us and Ben Busby is here and we are
here to answer your questions.
What we are going to do today is learn to
use EDirect to archive PubMed on local solid
state drives.
Where going to see how we can access the data
used in some of the functions now available
on EDirect , and we will also just point out
to you that you can search for terms, although
I want demonstrate that today.
We are going to show you the basics on how
to get records out of there.
I will also point out new features of the
xtract program and scripts that will point
out that you can process the data that you
get from PubMed locally with xtract without
having to do any additional scripts.
That is the powerful thing about xtract.
Just a reminder, if you don't know what entrez
direct is, but you might be able to get caught
up if you check it out.
This is a commandline version basically of
the E-utilities which are the API for the
Entrez system.
That is limiting on what EDirect can do because
it has processing scripts and an XML parser
called xtract that are probably the most powerful
aspects of these programs.
The retrieval program outputs to XML that
can be piped to another EDirect program or
Linux utility.
You need to have UNIX or Linux to run this.
Today we are demonstrating things on a Mac
and the documentation is there and there's
a good manual that has lots and lots of examples
and you can link to that to find out more
about EDirect.
Here is a diagram that shows you the different
functions or different programs that are in
EDirect . Basically the idea is you can run
a search, then you can retrieve things from
the history server using an efetch program,
and you can process those output.
What we are going to do today is show you
how to use a script that will fetch things
from a local instance of PubMed.
Then you can use xtract to parse that XML.
We did do a webinar on EDirect and that is
useful if you want to check that out.
There is a link on this slide and that is
in our webinars playlist on our YouTube channel.
Many people are interested in text mining
PubMed and particular the abstracts.
If you take some human disease mesh term like
this one, heart disease[mesh], and do a search,
you get a lot of records and you would get
a lot more for other kinds of searches, but
this is about 630,000 abstracts, and you can
go to the send to menu in the Entrez web system
and select file and download records and can
use any Entrez database.
In this case you could get the XML of the
PubMed, which contains the abstract, and download
this.
This will probably not work.
It is a too large of set to do this way, and
even our APIs and in this case I am showing
you esearch, but it is showing a proxy for
any kind of API or any kind of programm or
script using E-utilities, those are going
to be slow.
Here is what the history server tells us.
Their 630,000 records that have abstracts,
which we already knew from that web search,
and I could write a command line with piping
that into efetch or fetch if I was using on
the E-utilities, and I could try to download
this and what you will find is probably it
won't work, at least not in one fell swoop.
It is to slow.
Just a reminder, the network service that
APIs accessing is very busy and a shared resource,
and access speed and the volume that you can
get from that is limited.
There are lots of ways around that.
Where going to talk about a way today that
will help a lot, I think.
You could get all of PubMed.
You cannot get it by going to the web.
You could download this by FTP.
You can now download PubMed Medline and you
can get a full XML dump without a license
and there's an annual baseline and you can
get daily update files.
Once you download it, the problem is you are
faced with several problems and one of them
is there is no provided means of random access.
The xtract can parse it but you're going to
have process the entire set in some way, and
that is a big deal.
There lots of people that want to do these
kinds of things and Ben pointed out to me
the other day that there are two sort of programs
ClusterDuck and PuRSSE.
These are basically pipelines to work off
of downloading things from PubMed . They would
benefit greatly from using the strategy that
we are going to talk about today.
This problem of the local instance of PubMed,
EDirect has a solution thanks to Jonathan,
and there are some scripts that now come with
EDirect that will install and update PubMed.
There is a script called archive-pubmed that
will install and update a local instance of
PubMed.
It uses our FTP site downloads the files from
there and you can use it to keep it updated.
This particular solution uses the Apple file
system on a solid-state drive to store records
in sort of hierarchal indexed folder system.
It uses Apple file system because that allows
you to have millions of files and folders.
Talking with Jonathan, this is portable potentially
to other file systems.
We don't have the real details on how to do
that, but it should be possible, and maybe
Jonathan has some things to say about that
at the end if there are questions about that.
There's also an index-pubmed script that does
similar things for words and phrases in the
local installation that uses the same sort
of strategies of files and folders, and EDirect
efetch, I should have a different name for
that there in the slide, can retrieve from
the local cache and it is 100 times faster
than the network service, probably an underestimate.
This link at the bottom of the slide, that
will take you to the portion of EDirect documentation
that talks about using the local Cache.
https://go.usa.gov/xQMY7
Here are just some examples.
We are not going to try to run the script
today during the webinar because it will take
a long time to make your installation.
Basically you're going to tell it archive-pubmed
and give it a path to some drive.
This is the name of the hard drive that Jonathan
sent me and that is where the data is.
And so this archive-pubmed script will retrieve
the XML from FTP site and make these hierarchal
sets of files and folders and it takes about
1 million folders containing 28 million comprised
PubMed records.
And there is that path to the folder that
would contain this particular PMID 12345678.
/Volumes/rose/Archive/12/23/56/78/12345678.xml.gz.
It uses pairs of numbers in the PMID to create
this tree , and then there are several pub
med records in that directory, but it breaks
the database up into manageable chunks.
It also has a feature of clean things up in
PubMed XML and you can run archive-pubmed
on a weekly basis or something like that to
maintain the database and keep it current.
There's also a similar strategy that you can
use to index this data.
You can use this index-pubmed, giving it a
path to where it is going to go (/Volumes/rose/Postings/c/a/n/c/canc.trm)
and it creates a hierarch set of terms and
files and folders, analogous to the way records
are stored.
You can go into the Volumes directory, and
there's a postings directory that has folders,
for example, cancer is broken up into this
/c/a/n/c/canc, and then all the terms related
to cancer in there.
This service allows unrestricted wildcard
truncation so you can get all variants of
therapy with an asterisk on the end, therap*,
you can do phrase queries, proximity searches.
The program that runs it is called local-phrase-search
and it counts and it will pull out the PMIDs
for passing to archive-pubmed for getting
around.
All of this is happening on this little hard
drive that is about as big as a cell phone.
It holds all of PubMed plus index folders,
and it is attached to my Mac desktop in NCBI
but it can be attached to a Mac laptop.
This is a 500 gigabyte that is formatted with
the Apple file system and attached to a Macintosh
computer at the moment.
And then here is some example command lines
and we will do demos in a minute that will
use some of these kinds of things.
Here's one where I can run esearch,
esearch -db pubmed -query "PNAS [JOUR]" -pub
abstract | efetch -format uid | fetch-pubmed
-path /Volumes/rose/Archive > pnas.xml
and I'm trying to get articles from PNAS that
have abstracts.
The upper part of this command line is coming
from the network service, getting the IDs,
not the records themselves, and then I can
use fetch-pubmed which is the script that
is looking into local archive here on Rose
and I will get all of these things out as
XML.
Here are some examples of the local phrase
searches, again pointing to the directory
on Rose, the postings directory.
local-phrase-search -path /Volumes/rose/Postings
-count "catabolite repressor*"
-query "catabolite repressor*" | fetch-pubmed
It can count them or get them, the IDs, for
you, and pass them to fetch-pubmed.
You can also set an environmtnt variable that
will make it so you don't have to include
that same path statement every time.
export EDIRECT_PUBMED_MASTER=/Volumes/rose
We are going to do a live demo.
This is one that Jonathan provided and it
is pretty cool.
Actually it is kind of a funny example, but
it demonstrates the power of using the local
Cache to getting records out and xtract and
being able to do essentially mining in PubMed.
You're going to go do some analysis, some
reformatting, some calculations just using
that xtract program.
Basically what we going to do is look at how
the number of words in PNAS abstracts changes
over time.
Were going to search pub med online for all
PNAS abstracts and we are going to process
the local xml for the instance of PubMed using
xtract options to show you their different
things you can do.
Two new things that Jonathan wanted plugged
is the -wrp option which wraps elements in
XML objects, you remake xml for further processing,
and -select, which we are going to use select
records by particular condition, in this case,
the year.
What I will do now is escape out of the slides
and I'm going to go over to my Mac desktop
and I will have to login because it is probably
timed out and we will look at a terminal window
there were we can run some of the scripts
and I'm going to have to flip back and forth
between the text, what you have also in your
handout section on the go to webinar page
and flip back to our Mac desktop.
Let me get out of here.
Here is a terminal window at the command prompt
and that is where we are going to be doing
our work.
What I'm going to do is pull up on the PC
side, these are the notes that are in your
materials section.
And so here is the kinds of things that we
are going to do.
We are going to run the searches and I'm going
to copy the command lines from here and we
won't have time to talk about all these different
things in these command lines, and I will
point out the important things.
I'm just going to copy that, go over to the
Mac desktop here and paste in the command
line.
That is just going to run esearch and I'm
going to show you how many we get, 115,000
if we do that.
Let's see what the next step is to get that
XML, and this time we are going to get it
locally.
There are some command lines here that contain
this path option to go into Rose to the archive
directory, but I have already exported this
environment variable here so I don't have
to do that anymore.
It knows where to look.
Here is the longest thing that we are going
to do today.
We will have to wait a few seconds for this
to run.
This is basically going to take these UIDs
that we are getting from the network server
and we are going to pass them to the local
instance of PubMed and get them out using
the fetch-pubmed script and you can time and
if you want.
Recently it has not taken very long.
20 seconds seems like a long time when you
are doing a webinar.
It did finish.
Let's just take a look at what is in there.
This is going to contain the PNAS XML for
all these different records.
What we want to do next is start pulling out
data.
We want to pull out the year that you can
see there and we want to go to the abstract
section of the XML and pull out the individual
words that are in their.
I will clear my terminal.
I save this file in PNAS XML.
You could do this in a single set of piped
steps, but I thought it was easier to do it
this way so I have that locally saved.
And that is going to put it into the screen
so you can see what happens.
It is going to not worry about stop words,
it will look in the pub med article for the
date and it is going to get the words from
the abstract and these -sep arguments and
the prefix argument here just sort of make
sure is that it all comes out on different
lines.
That would be what you would get.
You just go through each one of the records
one at a time and get that information from
it.
You could process that.
One of the things that you could do is you
could use a rather complex command line shown
here that would basically insert XML tags
into this thing.
It is rather large and complex, but it would
basically give you another set of XML.
The goal here is take the XML and reprocess
it by using xtract.
I will not run this one, it will basically
give you that.
But I will run the next one which uses a new
option which is this -wrp option.
It let's say with the tag is going to be and
you can put the data right in their.
Were going to work directly on the PNAS XML
file which I'm going to save as yr underscore
wortds dot XML.
Just wanted to make sure that that worked
okay.
It did.
We created a set of XML for each one of the
records there that is going to have the year
at the top, the individual words in abstract.
Again, you can do this to give you another
kind of XML.
It is going to count the number of words in
each one of the articles through this script
here.
I will call this countsByYear dot XML and
we can process the rest of the way with the
additional things in here.
We are using that wrp option to make XML tags.
We get the pattern from the new XML that we
made previously.
This basically points out that xtract is an
XML parser and we will get any XML as long
as it is valid and we made our own here so
we can take a look what's in there.
And now we have something that looks pretty
structured and easy to deal with.
That gives you the average number, and that
is for each abstract, I'm sorry, not the average
number, the number of words in each one of
the abstracts, you can see the top there,
2018.
What we will do is get the average of those.
Basically what we will do is use xtract to
use some the additional analysis features
that are in xtract to do that, and so I -- Jonathan
has made a shell script that will do a loop
using the years from 1960 to 2018, and then
it is going to take what is in that loop,
use xtract then do a new option that is available
in xtract, -select.
It will pass the year when it matches the
year and we will run the loop and get them
altogether for each year, and we are going
to get the average.
I probably did not paste that in quite right,
but to save time, I will get the year counts.
Let's just take a look at that.
That is what you have if you run that shell
script properly.
You are going to get basically a set of years
with the corresponding average number for
each year.
This is why we are on my Mac desktop because
what you can do is another script that's in
EDirect, this xy-plot.
Uses plot2 which is a Mac program and will
give you a nice little chart.
What happened over the span of years to the
Word counts in PNAS abstrcts, and there we
have it.
It launches that.
The number of words per abstract has gone
up since 1970, 69 pretty much and leveling
off right now.
There is probably only so much you can put
in their.
That is the full demo, at the bottom of the
script you can run this basically is a single
script if you want to.
We are at time, but I'm happy to leave this
open and we can answer questions.
Let me do that now.
Let me just go back over here to the slides
for a couple more points, and then we will
have some questions.
We did what we said.
We did this whole thing.
We showed that you could download and make
accessible local instance of PubMed.
The xtract parser and other EDirect script
provide tools for processing and analysis
of PubMed records and now I hope you know
how to do this.
And then there is a slide at the end that
you can certainly have, and it has some URLs
for some of the things we talked about and
some other things that we haven't talked about
in places where you can learn more about NCBI.
You can always write to us at info, and if
you have questions about webinars in general,
you can write to webinars and if you have
questions for me or Jonathan or Ben, I think
we will be happy to answer emails sent to
us.
Ben, do we have any questions?
[Ben] We do.
There was some discussion about putting stuff
on GitHub and I will pass it on to Jonathan.
The first thing I wanted to ask Jonathan,
I remember Jonathan, we had a discussion about
this a little while ago, and basically that
question can be boiled down to do you have
to use a Mac or can you use something like
CentOS with SDD Drive using the Andrew file
system to use this?
[Jonathan] The Mac APFS is why I built this
because by default it can handle millions
of folders and files, but there are settings
for Linux, Window systems thatone of the attendees
sent me and that will be printed out if you
are configuring on Linux, and Windows NTFS,
there is a way to customize the file system.
I just don't know what it is and I could get
someone that does know what it is to tell
me what to do and I could add that documentation.
It should be possible to configure all these
file systems to handle lots and lots of files.
That should not be a problem.
I believe the source code is included in the
download I believe it is copied automatically
to GitHub, but the source code comes with
the EDirect through the download.
Someone else in the chat said xtract doesn't
[ Indiscernible ], and EDirect utilities run
fine but the compiled code for xtract does
not.
I would like that person to contact me because
we did put up [ Indiscernible ] for rasberry
Pi so if it is not working, I would like to
work with that person to figure out why it
is not working and get it to work because
it should be standard that the download, the
standard setup script should recognize it
download it automatically.
If something is working, we want to get that
right.
[Ben] There are a couple other simple things.
Jonathan, correct me if I am wrong, someone
asked if you can use sort uniq rank count
to get word frequency, and since it's just
a wrapper of linux commands and you should
be able to use this for when you use xtract
for words, I don't see why not.
[Jonathan] yes
[Ben] Just reiterate something Peter said,
you don't have to rebuild the local copy each
time you do a project, so you can update it,
and basically if you just run the same command,
it will just update what you have.
[Jonathan] Right, Archive PubMed, the first
time it prepares the disc, it downloads everything
and it cleans it up in an archives it.
The next time it sees that all that has already
been done and sees that they're only a couple
new files, so it ignores all the ones that
have already been downloaded and just downloads
incrementally.
Daily or weekly you could run it and it should
take a few minutes to complete.
[Ben] One of our colleagues did chime in and
you do have to rebuild each year with the
new PubMed baseline.
[Jonathan] yes
[Ben] I think we have gone to most of the
stuff.
Are there any other questions?
[Peter] Great.
Thanks, everybody, for coming, and Jonathan,
thanks a lot for this webinar.
This is great.
Talk to you later.